so you said on a show you wanted two
houses yes do you still want that yes
okay where where do you expect to find
this guy that's gonna be she just just
to give you some background moldy she uh
Janelle but you deserve a condo at best
baby
she wants she wants yeah she she I think
she would pay you do pretty well and
yeah yeah okay so she'll she'll run or
buy one house he'll buy the other they
won't she wants to have separate houses
so she can have her space yeah because
this is the thing
you got that first one purchased wait
okay this is the [__] I don't don't
explain it don't explain it
yourself okay I just need you to answer
the questions okay where do you where
where do you where do you like to find
this
this very easily grinder do you know do
you know like especially coming from the
iPhone Community the way that I look at
life is so different I know I need I
need listen if I go to in person okay so
you expect to meet him in person she's
gonna get something